>> Dana: SHE'S A WOMAN WE WANT
TO IGNORE HER BUT SHE KEEPS
GIVING US MORE.
IT'S THE QUEEN OF HADES HAVING
BORING CHATS WITH GUTSY LADIES.
HILLARY CLINTON IS BACK IN THE
NEW APPLE TV+ SHOW CALLED
"GUTSY" WHICH REVIEWS NEXT MONTH
IT SHOULD MAKE JON STEWART'S
RATINGS LOOK LIKE THE LAST
EPISODE OF "MASH."
INTERVIEWING GUTSY WOMEN ALONG
THE WAY.
INSIDERS WONDER IF THEY'LL SKIP
WISCONSIN AGAIN.
[SPARSE APPLAUSE]
IT FEATURES MERCY A HARD, GOLDIE
THE SHOW EXPLORES LIFE, LOVE,
HEARTACHE, DESPAIR, OVERCOMING
DEVASTATING CHALLENGES.
IN THE NEW TRAILER, HILLARY
OPENS UP ABOUT THE GOT SIESTA
THING SHE'S EVER DONE.
NO, IT WAS NOT MURDERING
JEFFREY EPSTEIN.
[LAUGHTER]
>> YOU SAID THAT GOT SIESTA
THING YOU'VE EVER DONE IS STAY
IN YOUR MARRIAGE.
>> NOT RIGHT FOR EVERYBODY.
KIND OF LIKE JAMIE'S COMEDY.
ALSO GET A SNEAK PEEK OF HILLARY
TRYING TO BE FUN WITH
KIM KARDASHIAN FOR THEY WENT
HEAD-TO-HEAD IN A LEGAL QUIZ
MUCH LIKE A WHITE HOUSE RUN,
HILLARY LOST AT THAT TOO.
>> IT WAS HEARTBREAKING.
I WAS ALSO REALLY INTRIGUED BY
HOW WELL SHE DID.
I WANTED TO, YOU KNOW, PUT THE
SPOTLIGHT ON HER.
>> SHE HAS TO WORK ON HER
REACTION TIME.
>> Dana: WE TRIED CONTACTING
KIM FOR A COMMENT BUT SHE
MYSTERIOUSLY VANISHED WITHOUT A
TRACE.
WE ARE GOING TO KEEP TRYING
THOUGH.
IT'S A LITTLE MYSTERIOUS PREKAT,
WOULD YOU CONSIDER YOURSELF A
GUTSY WOMAN?
>> IF THAT'S THE SCALE...
I'M LIKE, SHE BETTER NOT SAY
THAT THE JANE GOODALL, WHO I
LOVE.
I LOVE JANE GOODALL.
I LEFT MY WHOLE LIFE BEHIND TO
LIVE A CHIMPANZEES BECAUSE
THAT'S WHAT I WANTED TO DO.
SHE'S LIKE, I STAYED WITH A GUY
WHO CHEATED ON ME A LOT.
ONE OF THOSE IS GUTSIER THEN THE
OTHER.
I DO NOT GET HOW IT'S GUTSY AT
ALL.
YOU DID NOTHING.
>> YOU PROBABLY DIDN'T GET AN
INVITATION TO BE ON THE SHOW?
SPEAK I DIDN'T.
>> I'M GOING TO
TRY TO FIX THAT.
>> I'D LIKE TO SEE HER BE AS
MEAN AS AS SHE WANTS TO BE.
HILLARY, YOU ARE A MEAN LADY.
WE ALL KNOW IT!
>> Dana: I AGREE.
[APPLAUSE]
>> SHE MIGHT'VE WON MY CARE WHEN
SHE WAS TALKING ABOUT KIM, I WAS
REALLY HAPPY.
IS THERE SOMETHING IN THERE
HOLDING THIS SMILE UP?
BECAUSE YOU ARE NOT HAPPY.
BEING MEAN.
>> Dana: JAMIE, WHAT'S THE
GUTSIEST THING YOU'VE EVER DONE?
>> COMING ON HERE TONIGHT WITH
THESE JOKES...
SOME OF THE JOKES THAT I'VE
SAID.
YEAH.
HER REACTION TIME...
I LIKE THE EXCUSE WAS SHE
DOESN'T HAVE A GOOD REACTION
TIME BUT NOT THAT SHE DOESN'T
KNOW ABOUT THE LAW.
HER REACTION TIME.
THEN AGAIN I'M THINKING SHE DOES
NOT HAVE THE BEST REACTION TIME.
SHE STILL MARRIED TO BILL.
[LAUGHTER]
SHE SHOULD'VE PRETENDED THE
BUZZER WAS HER EMAIL DELETE
BUTTON.
HOW RIGHT IS KAT TIMPF DOWN MIKE
THOUGH ABOUT IT'S NOT JUST THAT
GUTSY TO SAY THAT MY HUSBAND
CHEATED ON ME.
I'M GOING TO STAY MARRIED TO THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
AND I HAVE POLITICAL
ASPIRATIONS?
IF HE HAD BEEN A PARKING LOT
ATTENDANT IN POUGHKEEPSIE, IT
WOULD'VE BEEN OVER.
HOW GUTSY IS THAT?
>> SHE CONFESSES TO THAT.
SHE GOES, IT'S NOT RIGHT FOR
EVERYBODY.
EVERYONE IS NOT MARRIED TO THE
PRESIDENT AND HAS THE ABILITY TO
RUN ON HIS NAME FOR SENATE AND
BE SECRETARY OF STATE AND THEN
RUN FOR THE PRESIDENCY?
I THINK THAT'S WHAT SHE WAS
SIGNALING.
LISTEN, IF THEY ARE POWERFUL
WHEN YOU CAN GET SOMETHING OUT
OF IT, STAY WITH THEM.
THE OTHER THING I REALLY CAN'T
UNDERSTAND IS WHY IS CHELSEA ON
THERE?
SHE'S JUST LIKE HER MOTHER.
NO PERSONALITY, NO CHARISMA.
SHE'S NOTHING LIKE HER FATHER.
NOTE IT FACTOR.
IT'S DOUBLE HILLARY ON ONE SHOW.
[LAUGHTER]
I THINK THAT'S JUST BAD.
[APPLAUSE]
THANK YOU.
>> Dana: IS IS HILLARY TRYING
TO BE MORE RELATABLE AND GET A
LOT OF EYEBALLS ON APPLE TV SO
SHE CAN RUN AGAIN?
>> DID SHE SAY I'M GOING TO TRY
TO GET MORE RELATABLE?
YOU FOLLOW THE SAME PROBLEM THAT
KAT BROUGHT OUT.
JUST BE YOURSELF.
IT COMES DOWN TO AUTHENTICITY.
RIGHT?
THE REASON WHY THERE IS NO
AUTHENTICITY HERE BECAUSE SHE
SAID IT'S GUTSY TO STAY WITH
BILL.
IT IS HARD AND GUTSY TO STAY
WITH SOMEONE ONCE YOU DECIDE TO
DO THAT FOR THE RIGHT REASONS.
BUT AT THE SAME TIME, SHE'S
CRITICIZING AND DEMEANING THE
VERY WOMEN WHO WERE ABUSED BY
BILL.
IT'S A LACK OF LEADERSHIP, A
LACK OF TRUST.
THESE PEOPLE ARE NOT
TRUSTWORTHY.
WHY IS IT THAT THESE ARE THE
VERY BEST PEOPLE IN OUR COUNTRY
TO LEAD?
I REALLY HOPE THERE IS A NEW
GENERATION OF AUTHENTIC PEOPLE.
I DON'T HAVE TO BE PERFECT.
BUT BE AUTHENTIC.
>> I'D WATCH A SHOW WHERE
HILLARY SENDS BACK FOOD IN A
DINER.
[LAUGHTER]
>> OVER AND OVER AGAIN.
>> JUST YELLING AT THEM?
I'D WATCH THAT ALL DAY.
>> SHE TAKE THE HOT SAUCE OUT OF
THE PURSE.
>> HER IF SHE'D ORDER A VERY,
VERY EXPENSIVE BOTTLE OF WINE --
>> SHE'S NEVER...
BECAUSE SHE WOULDN'T BE AT A
DINER.
LET'S BE HONEST.
>> SHE BEGRUDGINGLY WENT TO A
DINE